Senegal has recorded its first death
from the global kovat 19 outbreak pop
doof a leading figure in French football
died in this hospital in the car moments
before he was meant to be flown into
France he came to the infectious disease
unit with flu-like symptoms and was
quickly put on a ventilator doctors
would not confirm or deny whether they
treated him with the anti-material drug
chloroquine Senegal has been using it to
treat patients infected with kovat 19 I
can't say but yes we have some good
results now because we have the number
of people here from this disease
growing up several people have died
after taking the drug without
prescription in France the United States
and Nigeria the World Health
Organization has warned the public to be
cautious of the medication saying not
enough tests have been done to prove its
effectiveness yet china says it
successfully used chloroquine for
treatment but it has not made its
findings public rich countries are
stocking up on both chloroquine and
ventilators leaving African nations
ill-equipped to deal with the outbreak
Mali Senegal and Central African
Republic combined have 65 ventilators
for 41 million people compare this with
New York City alone which has 12,000
ventilators for its eight point six
million residents for cash-strapped
countries chloroquine is a cheaper
solution than buying ventilators but
with a stock of only 800 boxes the drug
is in short supply in Senegal this
pandemic is revealing the weakness of
governments in the face of health crisis
because the decision to manufacture drug
or even to finance the research to find
a cure against an infectious disease is
mostly in the hands of pharmaceutical
companies and not African states this
pharmaceutical factory manufacturing
chloroquine shut its operation in
January it said the drug was not
profitable the employees that lost their
jobs want to go back in production this
until cancer flies yes of course because
you can make this work in people
and Africans on it we can make it you
can produce it we have to know that you
have the people do competence you had
everything while the factories
management is in negotiation with the
government
China is offering to supply the drug in
this battle to save lives the death of
pop Jeff has shaken Senegal and millions
of sports fans in France and
french-speaking parts of Africa where
more and more people are falling
critically ill Nicholas Hawk al-jazeera
at the car